let's go to our five headlines
okay number one kamala harris is joe
biden's vp pick
this is exciting news folks i i mean i
don't really care but
some people do so uh it's exciting for
some people
i'll have more to say about this in the
daily cancellation for now let me just
echo the sentiments uh expressed by
other people that this pick seems like
perhaps the worst of all worlds for joe
biden
she's from a state that biden was
already going to win
um she doesn't have an enthusiastic fan
base
she's hated by a lot of people left of
center and right of center a bit like
hillary in that regard so i'm not sure
what what the
what the upside is here other than the
fact that she checks the box
she's a minority woman she checks the
box and since biden announced ahead of
time
that he's gonna pick a woman and that he
especially wants to pick a minority
woman
well he can't claim now although he's
going to try to
but can't really claim credibly that she
got the job because she was the best fit
for it
he already announced that he was he was
ruling out
most people because of their
demographics um
so this is a this is a a check the box
type of pick and he told us that ahead
of time
but as i said there'll be more to say
about that in in a daily cancellation
number two the country of new zealand
one of the most remote
inhabited land masses on earth a tiny
island nation with a few million
residents a few airports a few
international airports
and with its closest neighbors being
australia the most sparsely inhabited
continent on earth
and antarctica an uninhabited continent
um so we're talking about that new
zealand just to be specific that's new
zealand we're talking about here okay
not any other
and and this country has been put
forward as a coronavirus success story
and a model for the rest of us to follow
and sure we could follow the new zealand
model all we have to do first of all is
is
uproot our continent and place it
somewhere in the middle of the pacific i
don't know we do we we need to be
floating out there with no one else
around us so that we can even begin
to you know be in the same position as
new zealand
but here's the problem new zealand is
now having a surge of new cases
and in response they're shutting down
their cities again going into lockdown
um considering postponing their election
and there are people flocking to the
grocery stores again panicking
here's here's some of that footage watch
[Applause]
this
now here's the kicker the surge in new
cases that i just mentioned
four people four
in one family and as far as i know none
of the cases are fatal
four people four non-fatal cases
in the entire country and they're
shutting everything down
and panicking like that so what can we
take from that for one thing
they're terrified because they have zero
herd immunity uh which which which makes
them more susceptible which is a good
argument against the lockdowns
but for another this is how new zealand
is handling it
if anyone anywhere gets diagnosed
they panic and shut down their whole
society and
and so when someone puts forth the new
zealand model
that's what they're suggesting we do
that we stay locked down
until there are literally zero cases
and as soon as another case comes pops
up again we shut down again
uh number three a black lives matter
organizer in chicago has come out in
defense of looting
on the basis that it is she says
reparations
take a listen i don't care if somebody
decides to loot a gucci
or a macy's or a nike because that makes
sure that that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about
them not only that that's reparations
that is reparations anything they want
to take take it because these businesses
have insurance
they're going to get their money back my
people aren't getting anything
anything you want to take take it is her
quote
imagine as a sane human actually
aligning yourself with
that actually you know being on the same
side
as people who openly state that they
have a god-given right to take
anything they want from anybody
so if you're aligning yourself with
black lives matter the organization
this is what you're aligning yourself
with is that really what you do you
really believe that
you think that people have the right to
just take whatever they want from anyone
um now okay so
first of all we've got a few competing
assertions here uh looting is okay
because people need the stuff because
they're starving
or is it because they have a right to it
because of its reparations for
atrocities that were committed against
other people 150 years ago
it seems like it has to be one or the
other right and either way of course
it's lunacy
and the idea that people have to steal
armfuls of purses and shoes from
designer stores because they're hungry
what are they gonna do eat the shoes
what what exactly is happening here
it's again lunacy and it's probably
pointless to spend much time explaining
why this is
because if if you hear an assertion like
that
and you actually find it persuasive
uh there's this there's you you are so
far gone psychologically that there's
probably no argument i could ever
present to you
to convince you otherwise so let's move
on number four um
there have been a number of attacks
already launched ads ads and
you know things launched against the
biden harris ticket
all of the attacks warranted some of
them more effective than others let me
give you an example of this one just
came out this is an example of a
an effective attack against
biden harris watch joe biden
kamala harris the most extreme
pro-abortion ticket in american history
and the agenda
to prove it a pro-abortion supreme court
and abortion on demand
even at nine months up to the moment of
birth all with your tax dollars
so extreme biden and harris believe
babies who survive abortions
should be left to die disturbing views
troubling policies
joe biden and kamala harris are
pro-abortion fanatics
women speak out pack is responsible for
the content of this advertising
i've been saying this forever uh this is
a winner for republicans
exactly what you saw there and this is
true
these are pro-abortion extremists joe
biden is a pro-boarding servant now he
might not really be in his head
you know any i i i think he probably
knows in his own mind
that a a child five seconds before birth
is a human being
uh or or you know or five seconds after
conception is also a human being he
probably knows that in his head just
like he knows in his head that
you know that men can't get pregnant but
he's pretending
that he doesn't know these things
because he is beholden to the far left
and uh and camilla harris especially on
these issues really is
authentically a far leftist this is this
is this is a winner okay to point out
that they are extremist this is not
something
supporting you know killing babies fully
developed in the womb
who are viable outside of the womb that
is
not a mainstream position
it's among pro-abortion people it might
be but among
just the general population it is not
and so this is absolutely something that
should be put front and center and i
think that's a great ad
okay number five finally i have to tell
you uh i was i was really thrilled to
see this article in vice as a member
myself of the arachnophobia community
uh as someone who has that disability
i'm tired of being marginalized and
excluded from society and vice is coming
to my defense here's the article it says
spiders are a popular video game monster
they're also an accessibility problem
the developers of grounded which is a
video game i guess made spiders the big
enemy of an
enemy of their new game then suddenly
realized a bunch of people were too
scared to play it
they decided to find a real solution and
then there's this editor's note look at
this
editor's note there are no images of
spiders in this piece because this is a
story about a phobia we have
decided to avoid including any imagery
that might trigger it
this is sort of like a an anti-trigger
warning it's a trigger warning that
there are no triggers okay great
let's go to the article says when you
first start grounded a stylish new
survival game from rpg developer
obsidian
where shrunken players explore a
backyard full of unexpected dangers the
game asks a surprising question
are you afraid of spiders the game
informs players quote the the game
contains spiders that are often much
larger than the player
if you're super not okay with that you
can enable arachnophobia safe mode in
the accessibility options
this is a visual only setting that does
not affect gameplay or difficulty
um and from there it's it's uh going
back to the articles as from there it's
super easy to jump in and move the
slider to change
and deform the look of the game spiders
from something monstrous into blobs with
two bulging eyes
a small but important touch you don't
even have to see the original design for
a spider the game forces the player to
enable
spider preview
and then okay this just this article
goes on for a long
a long long time this is a very long art
article
and uh talking about the accessibility
problem
of uh for arachnophobes people of the
iraq community
iraq not iraq uh that's what we call
ourselves
i just decided and the problem is we're
excluded from games that have scary
spiders
and this is something that has really
plagued me especially as an avid
gamer myself but fortunately video game
developers are finally addressing the
problem and i'm very grateful for that
but this is obviously this is what i
want to say this is only a first step
yes we can eradicate spiders from video
games
but what about on the rare occasion that
a gamer leaves the house
you know what if it's that that that uh
monthly or bi-monthly journey out of the
house
there are spiders everywhere outside
have you seen outside
it's horrifying there's little bastards
spinning their webs everywhere no
respect for your personal space
everywhere you go they're trying to
catch you in their webs they're trying
to you know
crawl into your ear lay eggs in your
brain
this kind of stuff happens so my issue
is
i i am not able to participate in
existence
really i'm not able to participate in
life in general
at least not to the fullest extent
because spiders are out there
and they're super scary and they have
too many eyes just far too many it's
weird
it's not right so something has to be
done for my community so we can really
be full participants in society the
video game
is paving the way but what about
everywhere else now here are some
suggestions
you could start by first of all giving
us all earplugs
so that the spiders can't get in that'd
be a good place to start
we could talk about you know some kind
of plan to hunt down all the spiders and
exterminate them
a genocide of spiders if if you will or
in lieu of that uh i mean listen
if you want to just give me some money
for my pain and suffering
i don't know maybe 10 15 million a year
uh from taxpayers that might
help ease my fears and uh heal my wounds
before the spiders can crawl in so these
are all things we could talk about but
i'm glad
i'm just glad that we are finally having
that conversation it's important
conversation thank you for tuning in to
the daily wire one of the fastest
growing conservative media outlets in
the entire country if you enjoyed this
video
uh be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content